three well-known station casinos set now
to be demolished red rock resorts
announcing texas station fiesta
henderson and fiesta rancho will be torn
down and sold off all have been closed
since early 2020. sasha loftis on this
story joining us live up in north las
vegas tonight sasha has more
[Music]
brian reaction to this news is really
down the middle some say they are ready
for something new while others believe
it is not the right move but those who
used to work at these properties that i
spoke with tonight say this decision has
really made them nostalgic for what was
it's the end of an era for several
well-known spots in southern nevada very
sad on friday red rock resorts announced
fiesta henderson fiesta rancho and texas
station would be sold off and demolished
this comes two years after they all
shuddered due to the covid 19 pandemic
people that don't have cars and
you know use that as a local hangout
now they don't have nowhere to go
marisha who lives near two of the
properties says she's sad but not
completely surprised
while trish nash who runs a real estate
business near fiesta henderson is
looking forward to what comes next i
rather look at the glass half full
and i i think something really will come
of it station casino says it hopes to
keep adapting and developing across the
las vegas valley but former fiesta
rancho employee ronald portillo tells me
this move to tear the place down brought
back a lot of memories my co-workers
were like a family you know that family
has since moved on but portillo still
hopes for the chance to work with them
again i hope they can they can give us
you know another opportunity to
in the new
casinos open as our community continues
to change you know i'm sure that
something great will come of it
the ice rink connected to fiesta rancho
here in north las vegas will remain open
per station casinos if you would like to
see that full statement released today
by red rock resorts their parent company
just head to our website 8newsnow.com
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now